Christian gain returns is your first
major acting role isn't it how has it
changed things for you it's been
incredible actually um I'm a heat-safe I
found myself so I I can sort of
understand the enthusiasm from all the
fans
it's just give me such opportunities to
meet like-minded people I love how the
show's affected people and people are
very passionate about it and I totally I
totally get that myself it's such a such
a great story
and when did you think when you're in
the show Wow we're onto something here
this is gonna be really big
well actually am after the auditions I
didn't really appreciate appreciate how
big it was going to be it was my mother
here's a huge Game of Thrones fan who
told me like it's the biggest sci-fi
series ever
I still get onto it but obviously the
first day on set so all the sort of
stats and I saw how big the production
was and I knew that it was serious
business I was very pleased
you got a great cast of characters for
the show as well because one of the
things that probably made it so success
as well as the writing and the great
books and everything the costumes and
the production values I mean what's it
like being with those guys on set
well obviously being the first time
after it's a great way to pick up pick
up tips on the craft and there's so many
experienced great experienced British
actors and that's you it's been an honor
to work with them all I do to be honest
about working with the guys that you
work in particular is because you've got
brand one of them here you carry around
a lot yeah he's a monkey on my back no
it's a lot of fun that because it's such
a huge production and literally you're
sort of broke off in your own little
world and you become quite close to all
the people you work with I had taken out
be very close
Natalya night al masud le I've joined
our little group it's a lot of fun it
really is it definitely feels like a
little family isn't exactly the most
talkative character is here
what's that like as an actor is it quite
a challenge to get the emotions across
that you need to portray without having
lots of dialogue to do it in well that's
the only way to play Hodor really is you
have to be real there's no other way for
me to can convey that you sad or happy
or I can't say I'm happy I'm sad so I
really have to have to fail a lot but as
I say with all this all sort of sets
it's Bo bailed and sort of alternative
realities it's very easy to imagine
that's actually happening how did he get
under the skin of his character well to
me I sort of just I think it'll make a
child I think he I don't think he's
stupid to be honest I was quite a shy
teenager stuff so it wasn't it wasn't a
million miles away from me to relate to
I think he just doesn't speak like a
choice in a way and hopefully someday
I'll come by that word but the word he
says it's not it's not really his name
but yeah it definitely definitely pills
and personal experience for him I mean
do you have I mean there's a lot of
conspiracy theories that yeah favorite
one so do you have your own wanna maybe
bath Hodor or his background and what we
can expect as I'm almost afraid to say
it because I don't want to put George
off writing it there's all sorts there
say he's a lost plug in brother there's
that he's the son of Rhaegar Targaryen
and old now there's this what's the
other one that he's the great other he
might even be the Prince it was promised
who knows that probably none of these
things you know
and you're George our Martin he'll just
be killed off and left dying in a ditch
somewhere
now if he did if you did have to die and
go and throw it so there's been some
spectacular deaths on there and more to
come
how would you survive if you could
choose anything how would it be well I'd
like to die fighting an army of white
walkers yeah they're just sort of a huge
action scene would be nice I'll enjoy
that yeah now out of those theories that
you mentioned do you have a particular
favorite one I like the cookie and
brother one to be honest I don't want to
give spoilers obviously and being so
careful not to give away spoilers but
obviously if you know this story Sandor
was fierce was pushed into the fire by
Gregor and who's to say that you didn't
do something to hold or a thermal when
do not give me way slightly special
slightly brain-damaged that's a theory I
like to Targaryen one too though so I
wouldn't mind a little pet dragon
there's loads of interesting ways I
could go but I'd say knowing my luck it
won't so I'll be interested to see what
happens tell me a little bit about the
atmosphere that you have on set because
obviously there's different sets I don't
know in different places you've got the
Croatia you've got Belfast and so on
different directors and stuff going on
what's it like what's you know if it
wasn't it's not quite depressing to be
honest Winterfell was always very gray
and wet and I was sitting it's been that
way to come across some camera but it
makes it easy to me it's just be part of
the story that way there's so elaborate
it amazes me how different like the way
the show's patched together woman that
you're in the desert and externally
you're in the frozen wastes and the next
night you're in sort of lush valleys and
fields but somehow it works somewhere
all works together if you could have
anything happen to Hodor what would you
like to see happen I would like to see
them on the Iron Throne
yeah I don't know how that's gonna
happen but sir I'm sure George could
make it work summer I think you still be
carrying around run at that point tossed
inside
there we go what are you most looking
forward to with the storylines apart
from Hodor and browns and sable Melly
[Music]
yeah I really like following Orias
storyline i she's one of my favorite
characters and obviously me as easy to
me as and she plays her so well yeah I
also I love the interaction between
interion and Charles dance Tywin I love
their storyline and where it's going
I love the animosity between them it's
fantastic I'm Charles what are your
favorite actors everything that's the
thing I haven't actually met him
yesterday
it's crazy I've been on the steel for
three years now I haven't met all the
cast but it's just such a huge cast I've
been a fan of Charles since ilium 3 I
believe I love the alien films and it's
an amazing after both him as an actor
and his character as well I hope Tywin
is one of those characters that you love
to hear love to be intimidated by if so
he's such a nice gonna swear there but
yeah it's just it reminds me of like a
headmaster you really hit but some high
respect at the same time that sort of
thing I think I might have had a Tywin
finger in my life at some stage I can
relate to you tell him that when you
meet Charles yeah yeah well I'm sure
that everyone everyone let's Charles
doesn't that rolls it yeah yeah I can't
imagine and being play about anybody
else but I think that's the case with a
lot of the cast and I think it's people
really got a right to be honest you see
it going on for years and years I mean
they're talking about now splitting them
according for the next things not in the
books in two to two series that could go
on for that's been confirmed yet to be
honest they were obviously we're only
actors we just do what we're told but I
don't know if the book is being split up
into two distinct parts or and we'll
have to see how it plays out
and these thing about being a fanboy
yourself I know you're a big fan of Thor
aren't you would you like to think
yourself in that at some point really
great you wouldn't know there's so many
characters in the Thor universe I would
love to play you know obviously I'm
hopefully too young to fan but I would
love to play Odin that was amazing but
then again you can't have anything
better than Arthur Hopkins I can see how
would you improve on that
I didn't think Volstagg was big enough
you know doodle characters yeah I
thought he was should have been bigger I
could have done a better Volstagg yeah
obviously the guy was great but I think
from the comics he should have been
twice too so there's so many villains as
well FF the series continues who knows
what happened hoping for it as well and
what about other things that you'd like
to do as well after Game of Thrones or
while you doing Game of Thrones you've
got time off but it happened not much
I've just done repres trait for the BBC
and that's right it's like a few weeks
actually the episode Ehrmann yeah I've
been auditioning for some really cool
stuff so we just have to see what
happens to see five stuff or bit of
anything no obviously a bit about I
think it was nice to do the period stuff
for a rep restraint it was very
different but sci-fi and the fact that
he's definitely my heart lies if you
found it I mean I see you saying this is
like you first major acting role but you
have been in the entertainment business
for good many years haven't you do music
and performances and stuff have you
found that's helped at all with you know
with you with your acting yeah well I
think yeah you have a you have a zone
like a performance zone for me it's the
same as Finn's the same for me to sit
down and play the piano or play the
guitar or sing on stage or play Hodor or
a different role it's all the same
mental mental space for me
and how do you kind of unwind after a
long day on set playing Hodel Warcraft
yeah he's Warcraft cake in three years
and I Wis 40 much time there so CMDA
medal but I'm not actually I might try
it ya know it's been 40 but Stein
they're really right after this actually
we let you get away and do that now it's
literally just beauty Christian and lots
of luck with the new series the season
not that you need it cuz everyone loves
it and lots of luck with future roles as
well thank you very much
you